you
we got 67 in there so a nice turnout I
expected to get some more since I fired
up a stream so we'll see how many in the
end end up jumping in you could wait
join
but maybe not such a great thing to do
if we're already a few rounds into the
tournament but certainly
just missing out in one round and
hopping in there's still chance to
compete for the top spot so let's see
how it goes it's starting in a few
seconds let's see who I get in round 1
of 9
okay three two
mix and burn
let's go with d4c for Queens gambit
declined
all right let's bring the Knights out
first
right there let's bring the bishop out
pin the night
try to grab the pawn and hanging on to
it I don't know if he could really be
hung on to
all right let's go III so there's no no
worry anymore about me maybe losing upon
this back off
my knight on c3 also stops this b5 move
if there are these thoughts of grabbing
the pone and trying to hang on to it I'm
never really sure I just I might as well
go here
in some positions you may want to go to
e2 so that pawn captures isn't hitting
with an attack against your bishop
there may be a different way to go ahead
and scoop the pawn up like that
or maybe like this I don't know
Bishop d2 d3 or e2 not sure the
difference in its particular case
okay
recapture 2 to 1 see 5 B 6 okay a six
with B 5 nearby
how do I deal with that
I'm going to invest this move I we can
be five but I stop be five so I guess
it's going to be b6 c5 get this guy out
I've strike at my Center not sure which
of the two is more important to play
first
maybe maybe striking in my center first
you
some other move a night move I'd be
welcome to a dark square Bishop exchange
even if it is helping the Queen to
develop me actually maybe not if not
here maybe maybe I just back off and and
say you know where exactly is your queen
going to reside all right so there's c5
here
on d5 the knight can take and then that
unleashes an attack against my bishop so
hmm
I guess I'm just going to castle and
prepare to recapture with my night so if
this happens it may be difficult for
black to finish queenside development
solve this
we deployed the light-square bishop
because on b6 that we can see six
so we'll see what what black comes up
with
hopefully black is not listening to the
stream this is three - it's much harder
to listen in on the stream for a three O
time control but all right let's put the
Queen here the corresponding e7 square
is not available for the black queen so
she could feel some pressure both my
rooks will be on the C and D files and
my intention was to take with the knight
but now the timing is is such that the
bishop will be there to stop knight c6
can I play this move I'm gonna give this
a shot actually I'm going to take on the
isolated pawn
still go opposite the Queen
and you know life is maybe a bit
difficult for the Queen rook can't get
to the C file so easily let's play here
for still kind of put a question mark
over the queen
I'm
prepared to take on the hanging pawn
structure
C&D ponds okay so oh but that losses
upon if I take here right away Bishop
takes Queen takes Knight takes pawn
takes rook takes I don't see anything at
that point but what I should play is
this first just get out of any captures
on c3 and then win upon
and let's go for
okay so I'm up a pond I now have a
two-to-one majority on the queenside the
a pond can become past tough to get in B
for so I'm really thinking about
something else what am I thinking about
peace improvement rook here Knight here
bishop here it's just inviting the rook
to ask where he wants to go to jump in
or none of the above
can also with the draw my queen
just guards from square stop rook c2
queen d3 or what's wrong with b4 I don't
know if I really want a weekend c4 so
easily
I'm going to say
that
eventually need a flight square so let's
get it in right now
not make a commitment with my rook or my
pawn or my queen so rook c2 is on board
maybe I go for it
just right now duck that
rook takes b2 okay rook c4 let's go here
I'm keeping pressure on a lot I'm
hitting d5
defending b4k I could win like a windy
five and I should
and well this pawn moves his pawn move
pawn moves her progress clean is really
short on squares so
keep going
if I want to give this square up so
easily
yeah let's go for
okay the night's going there
yes we're exchanging Queens
hmm
start with this some defense some
offensive d4
you
let's push this okay I didn't I didn't
even consider that that was a move
let's play rook here
they shook their if I can maintain this
the rook is dead if I could get a knight
to one of its that about it took the
pawn hmm
alright let's just sidestep the attack
back in play
not mine some trades have to watch the
clock
my opponent is down on time okay um that
is round one
let's see 78 are now in here cool
there's still three games going on so
let's check out a top game lucid chess
is going against D man one
how are things looking here at least a
draw for white and maybe that's the best
like ago yeah that seems seems like the
way right because white is down a couple
ponds
there's something better that white
could have done I'm not sure
still two games going on let's check out
this one
okay this should be meet very soon
watch out first
it's it's the only thing team way
mate in a couple
right there and there we go and one game
remaining and okay now the all of them
are now done we have a one minute wait
time between round between each round so
let's see who we get next round two
right around the corner hello in the
chat
can I still join yeah you can you can
late join
you
mermaid I'm not sure if I address this
thank you for the tier one sub the the F
gecko thank you for the prime sub andis
Ilyas thank you for the Tier one resub
four in a row now hello back alright so
I'm going to get paired against somebody
who is on one point one out of one most
likely
so let's see who we get next ok pons ROP
let's see first time hauling pawns ROP
from where don't know let's go with
knight c6 and having some fun with this
a typical first move and reply to e4
knight on c6 okay I'm okay with doubled
pawns
the idea is to to try and demonstrate
that the bishop pair is is more than
enough compensation for having a ruined
Queen side structure all right and let's
get castled and okay so what is White's
bishop doing not too much
about this diagonal let me put my
Livescribe bishop on g4 I think this is
the more annoying of the two when you
consider the light square bishop sin
this position I think mine is the more
annoying for now white isn't a pin
immediately gets out of it the same time
the same time this Bishop doesn't have
this retreat so should I give that guy a
kick now that the night is on pin is the
night ready to dive in here
I can always go here let me and let me
give this guy a kick first see what
happens just goes back alright I can
give him another kick find out huh
I may want to do that now let's go here
they're gonna threaten me I assume and
then I have this way to defend and get
the light squared Bishop Soph
it's nothing fancy going on here I could
always reap recapture but of course I'm
on the queenside to be taking the Queen
in some scenarios if let's say the queen
is on d7 rook takes Knight could be a
really good shot because then my queen
is under fire
so the LightSquared Bishop exchange
basically can't be avoided going here
I'm not sure what's really going on with
the bishop down that square so can I
just
keep moving forward I'm going to just
keep moving forward to developing move
keep in a stay in a position where I
could recapture and improve one of my
pieces I think I'll be recaptured with
my night if they take okay we're going
to have the structure change I guess
okay oh let's take that night put the
bishop here the majorities have changed
- no it's one of my better pieces the
Bishop on c5 this could be a little
sensitive on enough to so I actually I
may be thinking if if this capture I
take with the Queen I am generating a
threat then I'd like to get in c5 so
maybe I would not mind having the bishop
play here I could exchange and then get
rolling
I don't think I have much much else
let's let's get on with this so I do
have some concern maybe there's a way to
to punch a hole in my queenside b4 and
if this night could quickly get here
that would
I don't know that would be a really
great square for the night but the
timing is the timing right
if bishop takes here i still take what
do i take with probably the knight
improve the knight generate a threat
against the rook okay Knight there
um
let's put this rook here
got up you're ready to react quickly
because another thing okay so is this
nearby
how much longer can we hold off on this
tension
maybe a five flight square I'm not sure
let's go with a 5 maybe preventing this
b4 move okay taking like that I'm going
to take with my queen actually because
I'm sensing that there's gonna be some
pressure on my pawn and I'm gonna devote
my knight to having this defensive role
and try and make some progress on the
Queen side here okay so queen is hit
let's react let's go here I mean this
rook could challenge my queen if she's
going to these other squares my knight
offsets their night I could create a
passed pawn at any moment
I may end up in a pin though my rook
would be lacking some defense if white
puts a couple miners there but now well
now it seems like I should be going in
for a break in the center
and I think recapturing with the rook is
the best way instead of going for a
passed pawn this is allowing another
piece too prepared to now double
pressure on the night they have pressure
here
I kick the Queen away from defending the
night here
another's just that
might as well just double I am
threatening mate and a couple so flight
squared time
let's get going with my I could still
create a passed pawn I'm going to go
with the candidate passed pawn first but
one that doesn't have a white bone
opposite it on the same file
the knight doesn't have many moves okay
he okay so we're gonna have the Queen's
come off
got to take with the Queen here
rook takes I have that
all right I feel like this rook is going
to be misplaced let's go here
let's get let's get the flight Square in
and kick this rook off of observing
these ponds
do I get one rack off and then play here
and
go for that
this
close game close game
[Music]
steak
here I'm still on this I played in the
wrong way
I want to have an outside passer
misplayed it
oh it's not expecting that this punch
obese this pond should be a liability
it's take here with check
possibly get behind the pond
okay this should be a one king upon
ending yes
okay let's just divert the king away
from the e4 square
stop that guy from going any further
okay close ending there
I didn't like the decision I think
playing e6 was the downfall therefore
white in that out in that end-to-end
that endgame it created a passed pawn
but it was it wasn't
it was a liability believe
so there's still six games going on in
round two let's have a look at one of
them
how are things looking here pretty good
for white
probably improve the King look forward
to this advance although he although
here there's a check could also just
come over here abandon these guys if
there's a if this light square blockade
is too strong maybe even do that and
drift the King over
gobble up these ponds seems like that's
what White's going for to watch out for
any tricks bishop there is very solid
when that pond
and your white is picking up okay he's
just hanging on to this first and then
gobbling up these two right here
I don't think you know there isn't any
any thought of a wrong colored Bishop
stuff there's no rook pawns present
so we'll see
Slayer six one six thank you for the
tier one sub appreciate it man
Coolio you drew against a 2,300 Congrats
alright it seems like white is going to
take this one
so let's maybe check out another one
here
there's only two games going on before
round three begins things are looking
good here for black should be winning up
a queen queen versus two pawns and
bounce
fishy fishy sushi
it could be a little tricky with these
two white pawns
couldn't be a little tricky here there's
checked when this pawn and then
sacrifice the Queen for this pun I
probably should have grabbed the pawn
first boom get behind this sack the
Queen for this one and then and then
bolt
so there's still some work so this check
here another an opportunity to grab this
pawn take the pawn
alright that's I guess you could still
go like this but it's not that okay now
and now we're getting that in just grab
that pond no tricky stalemates so it
seems like chickened is gonna come over
with this one and that's it all games
finished from round two
let us see who we get here somebody who
has two points how many have two points
14 players were it's 2 points it's a
good opportunity to get in some games
I've noticed a comment or two from the
few Swiss tournaments I've run so far
good opportunity to play against some
stronger
some stronger players you don't always
get that with the arenas
but yeah someone's sitting in the chat
they they won against a 2300 who's the
2300
not sure
okay round three coming up see we got a
hundred now in there very nice
Oh drew drew you drew against 2,300 okay
all right team white let's try let's try
an e4 game
Knight f3 Lord kin
I guess rel opposed
okay don't have much experience with
this variation what is it the Sleeman
I hear Bishop here I think this is also
a move queen the d3
watching the pond there defending the
pond primary function
and
also keeping a watchful eye over d5
all right now that the bishop has moved
I feel a little bit more confident about
bringing my knight here oh can I
consider capturing the knight winning
this poem probably not boom boom boom
I'm sorry hang on here here I could
exchange Queens first okay let me just
see oh oh no no no let's let's run it
like this I was thinking after this
black gets to Castle right away but
that's a blunder
so yeah now it's that move first so
maybe no maybe now I bring the bishop
here
if I take the night my opponent has the
bishop pair I've doubled their pawns but
I think that that's a very strong pawn
on c6
boxes out my knight on c3 very well I
want to keep this square as an option
from my knight bishop queen primarily
the knight
this is certainly a sensitive point in
my camp currently unprotected
there can be additional pressure once
castled
so we'll see all right that seems like a
good move
let's back off at least say if you take
my bishop I have some play with my rook
my opponent has the bishop here
probably good idea to get this exchange
in soon
castle's I thought about this move for a
second setting up some trick but once
black knows that this pawn is poisoned
I'm just inviting the bishop to a
preferred square
by playing this move first I'm stopping
this reaction because I could take and
you can't take towards the center so
[Music]
I am actually considering taking with
the pump
yeah as ugly as that looks double
isolated ponds I think it's very
important for me to have a file for my
rook and control over this f4 square
I don't think castling queenside is a
good idea so let's just go kingside
castling queenside is demoting the rook
oh no no not so much but I like keeping
the wreck on the FO
so we'll see should be roughly equal
I think
oh great benefit to either side here and
I think can I try to weasel on in here
now maybe uh maybe I maybe I think I
maybe black is better a tiny bit
yeah starting to feel some pressure on
my my kingside
this is a blunder take take
taketake in the knee for I'm in a fork
Oh could I have okay castle is my last
move here can I try oh I could try to do
something like this well let's let's go
for this move actually Knight g5 trying
to try to kick the bishop off of this
diagonal maybe I could be a little
greedy maybe this is this is okay this
pawn is unprotected on c7 my knight is
unprotected
but generating a threat there's no Queen
g6 to watch out for maybe the Queen and
the knight converging on h2
that should be easily defended
especially if this bishop isn't around
okay so the bishop simply sits
a six maybe
maybe I sneaked in this useful move
flight square keeps the knight out of
this square I have the knight I think
under control
this is possibly
square black can exploit
eventually I think they just give me a
boo
k-rock there I just double up broke f3
rack f1 they're gearing up for this
advance
you
do I go one or two
oops
yes I'll go to
oh here I could okay so I guess I'm
capturing now boom I don't see anything
going on in the a file at this stage so
these tricks okay so I can exchange a
Brooke I could also okay this night is
not controlling this score anymore I
think now I dive in
night here can be annoying I think I
might have to stop that let's stop that
move first here here could have been
pretty irritating I don't know if I
would have been able to defend e4
anymore definitely take with the rook
be losing h3 my
eyes would be shut on f1 if I recapture
at the pond so definitely recapture at
the rook here were both under 30
okay boom next up here okay exchange
rooks first
I get the Queen's off um actually I'm
gonna go here defending h3 and now I am
prepared to take with the pawn and have
these guys kind of mended some they're
no longer doubled and isolated in this
ending and now force the Queen's off not
sure how to recapture
this is tempting and take with the pawn
have some space
prove the king this is close I don't
know
not sure how to assess this
I'd like to get in this move move the
night and then this if I did that right
away okay
not sure
you
okay Oh am i winning this palm now so
tricky still very very tricky here maybe
this first I want to control the night
this pawn isn't going anywhere I don't
think
first and then return get my knight back
in the center soon
can I win the King and pawn ending if we
trade nights
not sure if this is the direction I
should be going
I need a time gainer let's get a time
gainer in there
and I get this check-in allowing me to
drift over in this direction so am I not
going to get trapped
yikes you might get trapped
he might get trapped
oh I'm going to lose upon
my knight is in left field over here I'm
in trouble
be helpful if they
capturing they're just going pawn
hunting
all right I think I have to try and go
after this pawn and I don't know
oh they allowed me to get that check in
I think the King stepping over would
have been better it's a race
here here
okay here and then here
check run and I could take here next I
think I was dead they should have sealed
me there
okay it's not over they're going to be
there in time to track my pond down
let's go one step here but I could
distract the knight here and then here
can't take I promote
in the corner I should be able to force
zooks whoa
should
still very tricky I think
let's try this
come over with my other poem or my other
pun either pawn my king
gather this pawn up
okay now they have to back off King here
I could exchange Knights
okay just
that night to sacrifice itself for both
of my pawns
okay get this guy rolling
you
see they were thinking
let's get going
another step
oh they're down on time think I'm toast
one key move right here recognizing that
my only idea is to get here step over
and I'm toast
I'm definitely strong I'm definitely
struggling I don't know how I ever get
out of this quadrant whoo good game I
feel like I definitely got away with one
there okay there's just one more game
going in this round three let's see
Bishop versus three pawns inbounds
can white hold yeah I think so this
bishop is exactly where it should be
that pawn and then sneak over
you should be winning both of these
pawns this one should end peacefully
a hundred movie game whoa
what a battle this one was
I don't think we'll have any loss on
time
I don't see any any tricks really in the
position may be king here Bishop back
King here if you could take the Ponder's
promotion but just stay on this diagonal
and there's nothing that black can do
might have repetition that's a little
bit scary well this might be a loss now
this was the best spot for the King
black is winning
you
yeah the king is shouldering off the
white king now
pounds pushing through that king should
stay on f2
Bishop stays here and there's no
progress for the black pawns so black
will get this one
no stalemates made next in four
different ways
okay that was the last one around three
so let's see where we're at with the
standings there are seven of us who have
seven seven with 700 or 800 and eight or
now in there
the wicked boiling the twitchchat now I
haven't been following it closely
did I say seven seven seven players with
three points
let's see who I get next
it's Paige - looking like Coolio
two-and-a-half outlier 20/20 what's
two-and-a-half still a lot of rounds to
go
so even losing an earlier round
still still rounds to make up or finish
with the good results so around four so
far so good it's running smooth
let's see we get okay prime let's stick
with this
96
on d4 I'll go for this
all right let's let's go with still a
French like play
you
you
just want to be prepared to put upon on
d5 see how white reacts and go from
there okay so
we've been here before
in this tournament the bishop playing
here
that bishops pretty good even though
this is my good Bishop I think that this
is such an active diagonal for the four
white star square bishop that it makes
sense to challenge it
recapture at the Queen in this case
um here here no why am I thinking about
night here
you
snipe belongs here now let the dark
square Bishop Saar exchanged I think the
knight on f6 is that much better now can
I not I should have maybe considered
pawn hunting instead of Knight f6
although I okay my mind was on
developing which isn't
bad train of thought to be in there but
what about now that I have this
additional developing move in I could
win upon let's consider boom block boom
I always play here and weasel back
should I be a pawn hunter
I'll go hunting for a pond
you
so let's see how they okay they go with
the night
I could actually shift gears now because
I expected C 3 so instead of taking the
beep on I have night takes here
no trickery with discovered check
because the nights in the way so chop
here c3 I can take here with check and
then get my clean out of the line of
fire so I think I'm going to take this
Center pon more valuable than that beep
own
I also I mean even though taking the be
pons breaks up these guys
you know there's maybe a reason to take
the b-pawn but okay I think the center
pone is the more valuable here I'm not
allowing the rook to get any activity
along the B file there's no fear of
let's say my queen possibly being
trapped
she's recapturing in the center there's
just too many squares
find a safe one so now I could still
keep this tension
because I could always still capture
with check but
I'm gonna reason yes I'm helping white
to improve the night but at least
there's one additional piece exchanged
and I am up upon and threatening to win
another I'm not too behind in
development I just need to bring my
bishop out actually it's about even
development wise so I think I will go
ahead and grab another pawn if it's a
it's up for grabs
so what am I going to do now that this
white no longer has this pawn on d4 or I
could do is look into what squares it
was controlling and try to make use of
those squares maybe was preventing c5 I
may want to get this guy roaming
but my primary focus is on finding a
square for my bishop and putting a rook
on an open file I like this c3 square
for my queen
I'm not sure where this Bishop belongs
but I'm certainly sure where this guy
belongs so let's get him there maybe
maybe I as some moves come in they'll
have some more information as to where
this guy belongs but for right now put
the rook on an open file and I don't
think I want to see this pawn go any
further I don't like want white to
acquire any space on the queenside I
also like the fact that I'm fixing a
white pawn on a light square so this
guy's eyes kind of widen
you know in the endgame maybe he go into
pac-man mode chipping away the base
point first in that direction
okay queen there where she headed
really ready to pivot on on this square
I think I'm gonna sneak in a flight
square and interfere with possibly the
Queen transferring near the kingside
this is a really good defender even if
the Queen and Knight and stuff are over
on my Kings side but anyhow all right
I'm running out of squares for my bishop
Oh actually what about this move setting
up a trick the Queen isn't done enough
for anymore let's let's drift my queen
here now threatening
way to develop Bishop takes h3
context I take the night so this is
serious and I'm connecting rooks all
right so we have the offer of a queen
exchange
I also don't have much time on the clock
let's go for the coin exchange let's
also stop night here which can be quite
and annoying quite annoying piece
rooks
not afraid of the night jumping in but
the bishop I think I'll play here I
don't want to see that I want to make
sure the night is under control let's
actually go here right now stop that
move all together and look to know
improve my king
let's maybe get
changes in there
here
I don't think recapture my king is best
I think having my knight right here is
is the way to go put the night here back
up my bishop
I'd have to return in order to kick the
night let's do that
and they have a pun on a light square so
I want to I want to get this in soon
oh the night's trapped
I'm just saying that now
yeah
squarely that he's oddest he's out of
squares
saw that late they resigned okay I got
that one back to tournament whoa okay
there's still a lot of games going was
on thorium and violin viola in viola
also have four points so let's look at a
top game
many of them are going they only show
the top six
let's see chickened against Amazon River
17 how are things looking Oh interesting
in bounce queen night versus rook and
two bishops oh but the bishop is dead
yeah there's nothing I don't see a good
way for these two to coordinate are they
trying something sneaky I guess maybe
one of the better tries
should be just me enough you okay now
it's thinking queen here to hear there's
way to defend that but plenty ways to do
it at this stage no issue on the clock
this one should be over so maybe we can
check out another one white should get
this one chicken they'll get that
what about another one honorary citizen
whoo okay I think white is doing better
here because of the night positions in
the king position what's this move about
ooh he's giving up some control here
this last couple moves this King should
go in here and try a bolt okay we're
gonna have a race this Knight is
strictly defensive now I think I think
things have turned I think the King
position he could one this pawn
this one's defended try it again
okay now white realizes this night
should not budge but who got to go back
okay now these guys are going to be
exchanged both sides are going to have a
passer anything can happen
anything can happen this guy's fast
he's you're gonna sack you have a draw I
think it's going to be a draw
it should be a draw
should be a drum
you
yeah this'll this will
the night sticks around pivoting on this
square occasionally something like this
is the key squares this pawn goes
there's the fork and there we go that
one's over with and there's only one
more going let's see it
Oh with under ten seconds and we still
have a lot a lot more game left let's
see if black and try to convert this up
an extra pawn white working with some
doubled pawns okay if these were
exchanged okay now these are very ugly
but it can can black really make use of
this I don't know if this is a great
issue
cuz hmm yeah this this should be
horrible I think
I don't see a great post for the black
King seems like he could always be
sealed this rook exchange should be
avoided by the wizard and it is
you
back here maintains the king position
yeah this one could go on for quite a
while let's see
upon ending
all right so we're getting one exchange
in there
you
I have to get this guy we're working
here here and then maybe the King could
hide on this square and then maybe maybe
get the King here and put the pawns here
is the way okay stopping that this could
be an idea
this what this is a thread okay why it's
getting a position to check from behind
ah there's a main to threat if white
doesn't keep checking
oh it's getting Me's getting mated
checking than me gotta go here
Oh
yep
miss that uh that g4 move okay that was
the final one for round four and here
are the standings so we have four with
four I think I will be getting paired
with this one I think that's how it's
going to run again thank you by the way
those who are were entered in here
nice very nice turnout for this new
format tournaments 116 are in there
so thank you all for joining hope you're
all getting some good games in I should
be getting paired with violin one plays
for two should play three like currently
I'm considered the one seed I guess by
the tiebreaks
maybe performance is factored in for the
pairings but one should play four or two
should play three let's see if I'm right
let's see if that's how actually how it
works
no in this case ok chickened first time
playing chicken
um
how about a c4 game Gotti for d4 and now
see farm
okay I go at the forum
see if I could kick this night back okay
now they're going and going in for a
quick c5 now this can get sharp fast huh
so they're definitely prepared to go
back home if I play e5 they've done
nothing to stop me from playing this but
I'm assuming that my pawn will soon be
challenged so here here eventually d6
here here
Queen f3 there's Knight here shielding
the rook and this nights gonna this
Knight move is going to be really strong
I'm considering this um
yeah I'm gonna go with d4 I don't like
that the knight will be able to develop
with tempo but I also don't like that if
I don't exchange my d4 pawn off or my D
pawn off then it might just be a
half-dead pawn because of this grip over
d4 so my idea is to back off just a
couple squares I'm basically saying to
black I'm prepared to fianchetto by
playing Queen to d2 so let's get my
Knights out if here then I'll go for
this and then this
the timing is important so of g6 and
then here
I do one move later there could be some
tricks along this diagonal now maybe
maybe
I think I'm going to use the reasoning I
don't know
where my light-square bishop is best
placed yet but I'm pretty sure I know
where my dark square bishop belongs
maybe I do know where my light square
bishop belongs maybe I don't
let me see here
maybe none of the above yet let's go
here I want to play here and if night
before I could back off now in my rook
my Brooks eventually stay coordinated in
direct contact with one another so I
have this secure now should there be a
knight move unleashing the Bishop on the
e4 square
so rook c1 Bishop d3 I'm ready to now
castle put my other rook on the D file
eventually this is going to be the the
jump from my Queen night let's go
I may not want to move this truck
like maybe it's just going to be the C
file that's relevant so maybe it turns
out that it's just a wasted move if I
play rook to d1 it's a natural looking
because it's a half-open file but should
I just dive right in right now or maybe
consider something useful like a flight
square
night here right now
I think this is more to the point
yeah let's dive in see how these
things shape up this Bishop I'm trying
to in a way I think this Bishop can
struggle on b7 you know if I if I
eventually end up with the d5e for
central structure so right now I'm ready
to crash through an f6 isolate the d6
pawn double the F pawns
so how's black going to react to this
all right taking towards the center also
purposeful here
I could have excuse me I maybe could
have considered capturing here first
all right bishop there are night there
excuse me
huh
okay
we're taking with the night
take you at the pond that's interesting
okay
huh
this is aggressive but is it good
I feel like I could just play it in a
simpler fashion I don't have to make
this committal decision eventually I
think this pond will be challenged I
what I'm trying to do here is actually
eliminate this bishop and maybe I could
make my way into this square I'm also
setting up a bad for a good Bishop
exchange maybe we enter an ending where
you know dark square Bishop there's a
dark square Bishop fight
ah
[Music]
let's just throw this in for fun yeah I
don't know what kind of great progress I
make by doing that but he's probably
still just going to go there
I don't have this or anything but here
now not seeing it and so we're just
exchanging
you know let's get the light squared
bishop stop so this is basically what is
coming down to I this is my focus my
focus is try and show my bishop is
better than your bishop
good versus bad guy and this this
exchange is forced or maybe you have to
exchange here and hang on to the bishop
as bishop here worthwhile actually looks
pretty fun
whoa that actually might be a move
opposite color bishops put my bishop
here
you
you
no that's not working
I think that's working flight square
I'll go with the light square for a
flight square
is that working here clean takes I
should I should have maybe gone for that
let's take the rock
you
carick here
it's closed it's closed the bishop can
get active in a little bit
two moves and it's on c5 I think this is
where it belongs with c5 square only
have ten seconds
King on g2 I want to make sure you for
is secure
you
rook d3 queen d1 keep control over the D
file
during the pink tank here
ooh okay like captured we're about even
on the clock now
defend the pone maybe I don't want to go
here anymore maybe half three first okay
what about the sensor insert this check
whoa
in the corner now I'm getting there
queen
or may just go here
this might have been leading to mate or
something yeah they they just missed the
Bishop III move
okay good game back to tournament
there's still 13 going on lucid chess is
finish finished is four and a half
let's see another game this was the
other other game both of these guys have
four points so how are things looking
rook and two pawns
versus a knight he's getting the
exchange back however is inserting the
check first and then recapturing so
opposite color bishops White's going to
be the one trying to press being up a
couple pawns need a flight square
that's the right flight square he's cut
off
tough to get this guy rolling the lights
down on the clock
inserting a check
but if the rook is here there'd be some
kind of a mate
okay rook ideally placed behind the pond
this is a passer so this is going to
take some work
okay is that even a draw if the rooks
are exchanged I don't know I think it's
I think I'd be a win if the rooks are
exchanged
hey this this pawn is marching the rook
is in a spot to get behind gonna go for
that rook up there this is a point that
could be targeted g3 possibly okay has
some pressure on it
rook to one of these - okay pressure
here now the rook is in a spot cutting
the King off that's nice okay the King
moves I thought - h3 so could he can you
get this okay could the pawn be stopped
yes it could the king is there in time
now this problem is under fire I think
this should be a drum bishop back here
stop this guy
this pong gonna fall Bishop has to come
back but then there's that okay now it's
too many exchanges yes this will be a
draw this one should almost certainly be
a draw okay maybe we check out another
game
yeah this one's going to be a drum be
very surprised if there's a different
result so let's check out one more right
now forget about it this is the last
game now all right let's see
boobs are played with this one
um hello maze dog 91 thank you for the
tier 1 resub ten months in a row now 11
total
and Dube shmoop thank you for the 25
bits in hard dreamin thank you for the
100 bits okay this game is over a draw
on board where do we stand okay five
rounds in I have five I will be getting
paired up with one of these guys
lucid chess anthurium
violin
around 6:00 coming up in 30 seconds
hello Alan chess
how are we doing
you
tamer of dragons I see you in the chat
I am focused on the games so I'm not
looking at the chat during the games
let's see who I get next
around 6:00 so far so good it's been
going smooth no no glitches or that for
the tournament here let's let's try e5
d6
I'm gonna now let's go with this again
alright I'm gonna try and be ambitious
no night here first scaring me this kind
of stuff
all right now we're gonna try and be a
little ambitious with the g5 no but the
Jeep on one go
I have weakened my kingside in a big one
put the bishop here and put the night
here I'm prepared to
seven once he's kicked
and he may be able to jump into this f5
square I don't want to go in the center
for a couple reasons I don't know how
great it is to take on doubled pawns and
I don't know if I really want to unmask
this Bishop for right now the knight is
blocking the bishops eyes okay so this
is I think a very good move I
yeah so if I go here takes chop here
chop you're taking my queen wins check
that was maybe something if I was
castled because then I could take the
queen with Chuck and get a rook so if I
take or push I lose this palm but wait a
second
let me this guy's unprotected so if I
take here
chop-chop Queen here
how are you defending both nights maybe
my opponent made a mistake there
you
his intention was to take care right
away there may still be another move for
white
I don't think Knight takes is a good
idea anymore because of this
where am i vulnerable possibly okay so
this guy's unprotected is there way that
that could be taken advantage of I'm not
seeing it okay I think now I defend this
poem I could add some more defense now
if necessary I'm up upon this could be
vulnerable and I'd like to be in a
position to support it with b6 but that
can hurt
maybe I start with this move I think
this is the way defending a lot of stuff
the night jump saying I could take my
bishop queen everything is defending
here I think
why do I think here what do I want to
play this and then here I guess using a
lot of time okay now this or now I get I
play this move first one of my concerns
was that if I played this early there's
Queen a for hitting this point it's not
the case now if I did this before with
b8 okay
I think just castle yep castles this
guy's under control by upon these two
need supportive pawns okay so I guess
here but the rook here if this probably
that that move
let's get to half-open file the rooks
doing nothing on the B file
where's this night going ok he's backing
off light-square bishop exchange I guess
maybe I'm defending this that's the
primary reason if my light squares can
be sensitive no doubt ok a nighttime b4
okay so our exchange Knights think
having a night exchange isn't bad is
this maybe is going way off into left
field or
do I take the night or play here and
then look forward to this move with
tempo now I think the pressure on this
is too much let's exchange Knights and
now maybe look at this move yeah I think
now we push
check irony prove my king eventually I
don't have a lot of time I'm prepared to
take with my king mama night I could
move the night and be prepared to
recapture at the pump
I want my King on this square if I can I
could play Knight f5 okay my king should
stand really really well on e6 my knight
could use some work right now he's not
doing so well with the pawn on g3 boxing
him out
so my knight needs to reposition this is
this is White's best piece
I'm gonna weasel around here fish up
there okay what am i right weaseling
around for what am I saying
this is this is tough now they're
getting play for the rook it's not fun
when it has some pressure has some
really good pieces I'm up upon but they
have a strong night better rook
not sure what I'm aiming for here knight
on d5 and then what
okay let's get here night here I could
back off control that night here okay
now maybe I could get one rock off my
night is defending this point they
should double maybe I okay what's that
rook up to well let's push here oh I
have this covered my pawn is pinned I
may have to move my King soon yeah
they're being sneaky let's go here I
guess here felt weird eventually
something with e4 I don't know maybe
maybe I'm close by with this move now to
try and get this it's not it's not easy
just go back if they do that yeah maybe
it may have to go here in the end I
guess we're trying this I've abandoned
any idea of my King maybe trying to
defend my base points on the queenside
he's all in on the Kings side
I guess we're going to try to get one
rakov is that pawn if they allow me to
capture here's a liability I think I'm
going to say it's a liability
when I say I don't have much time now I
need my king back over here need some
help
night right here right here and then
here gather up the pond
try it
on the pond
twice night on c4 bishop here just
defend everything
it's a big pun this Bishop but he's
defending me five here grab the pawn
let's recapture first Kings out of play
not doing somethin nice long diagonal
but he's not hitting anything now
now I'm up on the clock let's get this
pun okay get active with the rook
control the night
just defend this pawn on my list now
um King there
or should my night be maybe just right
here
well no no no I must drop my rook
might return soon
the Bishop of
and now there could be some tricks here
take
get this also seal my rook in other down
on time who they had all I was up upon
for a while out of that middle game but
they had pressure on me
okay two games ongoing no check that one
game remaining this one here another
rook and pawn ending this guy's going
this way and this should be a draw grab
the pawn and blacks going for more
I guess
here and then here there's not going to
be any mate
dead ban clawing his way against my name
is Monde
final game for this round six
you
we're going to get this pawn soon
you
take the Wow you can take the rook
what
so I don't know what just happened there
right that was a free rook was it not
that pond wasn't one step away from
Queenie he still needed two steps the
rook would have been there in time to
track him down maybe a mouse lip you
wanted to give a check or something I
don't know they play it on rook versus
rook
all right
let us see yes going for some trickery I
see in the chat
he's trying to flag and forgot maybe
this is increment though
you
they might have to go the 50 moves maybe
there'll be another opportunity for rook
captures rook free of charge
you
it will end eventually
maybe trying to catch a pre-move says
Isaac can we watch another game well
this is the last one for this round so
there's no other game going on in the
this tournament
and I don't want to look at any other
game
the tournament
just wait it out
in round seven will be next just three
more to go
we could let have a look at the
standings instead of looking at this so
let's let's have a look at the standings
so we're still in there with 116
participants I have six these guys here
they were ranked 45 46 so all right I'm
at six lucid chests five and a half
outlier five and a half I will be
getting one of these two next okay that
game is over I imagine it finished
peacefully all right so
who will I get I didn't know I didn't
play lucid chess I didn't play either of
them so lucid chess has a brown half
that means he played a game and it drew
this is a gray half which means a bye
okay late joined so outlier is basically
flawless he just entered late and has
won every game he played some let us see
around 7:00 I'm glad it's going smooth
so
no glitches let's see who we get
you
kitty warrior says I just joined
twitchchat Hello Kitty warrior
all right let's try a d4 game I
against outliar 2020 from
not sure fairly new account outlier okay
we have a slob on board
they're gonna grab upon yes okay I'm
gonna go with the variation that is very
sketchy
very sketchy
where I'm giving up two ponds
I hope to get one back
you
let us see
if I could manage
this is maybe a better variation to go
forward with if there is a if it's a
three oh game instead of three two
so
two pawns looking yet one back I'm
looking to make use of my
better development see if I could manage
now if they try to cling on to c4 I have
Queen c2 I've had a game go Bishop a6
Queen c2
and then the night moves
and defends the pawn
then I have Knights e5 or even Knight to
e5 hitting this pawn for a third time
let's see
let us see maybe they waited for me to
share that commentary before they made
those moves okay
clean there
yeah
sharp
sharp move
you
so if I try to crash through here my
clean I end up dropping this night um
think I've played with b3 before night
c5 Knight c5 there is this check the
queens are gonna be off I don't know if
there's much I could do about that I
think the Queen's are coming off
all right let's play 9c five
III
here they could have a past beep on
so weird position I'm stopping this
night from developing my night could be
kicked
maybe get maybe threatened to take you
and then take here or some some order
capturing on a six versus if B - I think
I gobble that pawn up night B 5 out King
D - I don't like my bishop position if F
6 I guess this is my only move and maybe
could put pressure on like that
this is my best piece my knight on c5
let's see what black comes up with here
you
you
I don't know if I'm threatening to win
this piece on a six somehow there might
be some in-betweener
okay that's interesting
just a bishop retreat so I could capture
here
and why not
yeah let's capture here
now I'm threatening to just
you know
all back I'm only down one pun is if
this I get to recapture and I was
thinking I'm threatening you to take
here that at the end and but still I get
to recapture and develop so that's nice
the extra pawn is not the healthiest in
the world
let's recapture right away
think so there isn't any fear of this my
night controls the bishop and I'm
currently threatening Knight to b6
winning in the exchange also important
to note that I'm on this night at the
end as otherwise this pawn is very
hungry
so they took my night
let's just recapture I have really good
development okay my night is hit
should I be reacting to that
home
you
where should I go with my night if
anywhere I mean
I'm not gonna budge I'm gonna put my
bishop on a
better square and be prepared to kind of
superglue this guy in there on d6 I
think
Bishop should be an incredible bother to
black that's what I'm banking on and
it's not easy for this King to find
shelter on f7 because of my bishop so
where is this knight headed maybe here
so
all this night first
I don't want my M Bishop to be
challenged so easily right night there
yes my king is going to have this
responsibility I want to move my bishop
and then give that Knight a boot
that's what you're going for I see
suppose this though I have some quick
pressure against this pawn I think it's
falling
or I could take
I think I should yeah let's take so I'm
back
material
mom is pawn threatening the rook King
there's a worthwhile to insert the check
should probably win this pong maybe kick
the night first
that night might be this night might be
dead
all I have a trick I have a trick if the
night goes here I take King takes and
then give a check and then when the rook
I got it I got the trick chop check
and then I get the rook if I just went
for this pin idea which is the only
variation I believe black calculated
they're able to get there in time to
defend
okay back to tournament land I got that
one putting me at seven now
two games to go two rounds to go let's
have a look at another game lucid chess
against chickened
our things looking here bishop in pond
versus knight in bounds
as concerns me the King position a
little bit is there a way for black to
we have a mate now I don't think so it's
kind of close if this night was already
here something
controlling that square there is not
going to be a main now light should be
winning this
up the extra pawn rook is hit the white
king is very active
he's gonna get this problem it's not
easy this and I could grab this pawn
make a take here
okay black eye okay this should be equal
now but it feels at this stage now that
there isn't a white pond now
one side of the board is this now the
kingside has been exchanged this guy's
just out of play the King white King is
out of play
that this should be this should be a dry
yeah
I sure thought you shouldn't capture I
think it's a losing king upon ending
boom now that should be a draw just by a
tempo
so I think you could have captured the
night they're black I guess going to win
this pawn outright
let's see
wasn't uh chickened one of the last
games playing and one of the other
rounds King here and then this stuff and
you can't take in that position because
it would be a winning King and pawn
ending so
this bishop I think does well to stay
here the king should just go here forget
about trying to hang on to this pawn put
the King here and being a spot to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn
so I think this King is going in the
wrong direction you should be here
it's gonna know getting ready for this
pond to make a March
this could work as well
now he's ready to take the night and
take the pawn okay now it'll be a draw
I guess you have to give a check Bishop
takes pawn next and will it be a draw
maybe repetition
Bishop takes pawn drop ok view the
tournament back to turn when we go and
that is it for that round seven okay so
I am going to play one of these two next
lucid chess versus chess ds1 are lucid
chess or chess ds1 both having a good
tournament so far performance rating for
lucid chess 2281 chess ds1 2122 I'm in
there
2492 at the moment
twenty-two ticks to go
maybe we could see page two
page three
29 players with four points or more
going into this round eight
all right who's it going to be I think
chess ds-1 no wrong again
all right lucid chess let's play e4 this
time
all right care care will come
let's really say carrot carrot come all
right let's go like this stop any Bishop
to b4 stuff so
first secure efore
upon in the center
my intention was to fianchetto should I
still go for that
I'm gonna say yeah I mean I have this
door open
but I don't know if these squares are
any good here here is going to be
subjected to a queen night attack one
way or the other and here
I don't like that because my queen I
think I need to be prepared to move my
queen eventually
and I think e 2 is the most secure
square for my clean so I'm going to
reason that G 3 is a good it's better to
put the bishop on this diagonal where it
secures e 4 really well and also say
that my king one day will like the G 2
square
that should be a nice flight square
and I can also look forward to getting
getting my f-pawn rolling one day
ah let's see Oh some trick I have found
for a couple times is Queen takes g3 my
my pawn is pinned so I've played this
before a couple times in this variation
the carro
yeah Queen e2 Queen takes pawn so maybe
I should play king h2 or King King to h1
it's kind of tricky to which one I
should play maybe Bishop f4
maybe Bishop out for
yeah let's I don't I don't know if I
really know what Square is best for my
King let's just go here okay so now I
could back off
you
feels weird my bishop on that square but
okay here we are
I'd rather have my rook on d1 right now
maybe I should have done that
rook d1 and then and then Bishop no I
couldn't have done that first okay let's
play this that would have been illegal I
couldn't have played rook d1 before
Bishop here
if I had played this move I'm just
inviting h6 with tempo alright now it's
a different story
because the night isn't a pin let's
let's just do that this is a sensitive
square
alright so the bishop just backs off
Queen Queen should have the
responsibility right now of stopping
Knight c4 we're going to have at least
one rook exchange
all right
keep the bishop I think so Bishop here
also watches over possible pivot rook d4
one rook exchange this night could do
something else
how do I make progress
they have to bring my bishop back
yeah I think I need to bring my bishop
back I can't play this move easily
because I lose that pawn I want to make
sure this Knight does not hurt me right
now this guy's under control pretty well
by my by my knight I want to make sure
this Knight doesn't get out of control
getting into C form
all right
yeah this this um I don't know maybe
maybe I improve my king
not sure maybe we're just going to have
all major pieces come off setting up our
Queen to d8 I guess we're exchanging
maybe I get this pond one day clean
exchange
and try to
do something good with my bishops
I guess I have a decision as to how to
recapture
I may want to take with the pawn not
sure
and my pawn at least has the
responsibility of keeping the knight out
of
a lot of ah the C 4 square now maybe I
like this I'm going to take what the
pond try this
structural change and I have I have this
break
flank pawn hitting the center pawn maybe
I could
should I should be looking to challenge
this guy get my center pons moving
let's go for right now yes then King f3
this is a nice
host for my king not sure where this guy
should go
let's see first of all how they defend
my recapturing like that okay
let's improve the King
they may be trying for a bishop exchange
okay that one's weakening the light
squares quite a bit here and then here
I'm going to try this
there's some light-square weaknesses
over here so they want to keep this
around
here
a ship deform way down on the clock got
to play faster
yeah
let's go here
while my bishop on h3 like yesterday
Stewart tonight has this square
I'd have to weaseling like this I am
think I did think about clamping down on
this structure with h5 but I may want to
actually keep that square open for my
king
I'll do it now I don't want my bishop to
be kicked
I think I'm going to transition
yeah I don't know how to
this
not sure
there's still ponds on the dark squares
so
you
okay feel that I'm worse or maybe not
and I take with the pawn miss planning
this
yeah I have misplayed this should have
maybe given a check
you
this King goes too far I get this poem
my knight wants to be an f5
threatening this pawn right now
that's what I want
Ochs that night out
take
here
you
check
and I ever make progress
I don't know
progress
huh
this pawn is so strong my king can't get
over on the Queen side
you
really
you
by Kings there though
you
I want to stop that break
seal the king off for a little bit
here
get my king is the block hater
yeah I think they were too ambitious
there
a night here and then got gobble up the
pond take like this if they try for a
passer
who
progress if we just kind of went back
and forth here I got lucky to win that
when that should have been a draw I'm
pretty sure that's my assessment I was
actually fearful at this stage after I
played King back that they maybe make a
break and their King make some inroads
over here they played that well
maybe I could have done so
than different here yeah I mean they're
starting to focus on my week square d4
pretty well good game lucid chess that
was very close and I guess that was
maybe one of the last games so the final
round coming up
this one is gonna finish so no glitches
for this Swiss that is still currently
in beta
and seconds before around nine I will be
getting paired against Ches ds1
let's see he is having a very good
tournament
HSD s14 round
9
see what we get all right I'm gonna
stick with this
96
pressure on me - on the clock that
ending
let's see okay
keep it French like is my opponent gonna
grab some space that is an option
enticing this move
let's see
all right now we have an exchange French
the Knights on
their favorite squares for the most part
hmm
you
I want to set up my pieces
ah is here for starters
I have to play here if Bishop here
if night here Bishop here I don't really
want to take my bishop
all right so we're going to have an
ending possibly clean check queen block
and yes you know how to capture king or
bishop
Bishop I give this guy too good of a
development so I guess I'm gonna go on
castled I'm there in time to get my rook
active and then tuck my king away
Bishop here Bishop here night here with
sting
with check
set the palm
all miners on my sixth
let's see
the more the position gets simplified
the safer my king will beam
so let's see
her starters let's just ask this guy if
he wants to keep the pin there or what I
want at least be in a spot where if I
need to break the pin I could in one
swing
so okay they're just taking so recapture
with the king and I want to end up with
the double isolated pawns my king is
moving forward Queens on the board this
would be crazy decision to have the King
this far out but it should be fine
and now
and now
for a second I thought about this that's
dropping that so maybe
what I want is this guy here so I'm
going to move my knight to
square night on e7 preparing now c6 hits
with tempo and I'm starting to I up some
some square here King side f4 is a bit
appealing the weakest square in my camp
right now it feels like it's e5
many white pieces intersecting on e5 any
stage the knight can jump in so I may
want to fight
for this square
there's this move concerns me some all
right let's start with start with c6
i times in
you
yes
you
you
King is a little short on squares they
want to get that guy safe soon
let's go here first I may have to do
this like if there's some rook left g6
King g7 actually I'd like to have a
trade of light squared bishop s-- even
though I'm playing with the bishop hair
I think no no my knight could be pretty
good if he's on f5 and unchallengeable
by a bishop can rely upon this post I'm
stopping any Knight g4 even though my
bishop is here this is a better defender
I'm weakening g5 but now that the knight
is played here enough to worry about the
knight going to g5
so soon so I could do this I think I
should play
hmm let's play this move first
it's maybe
discourage F
five
my idea here is with rook d8 is to
exchange bishops without fear of a night
landing on d7 I don't know how dangerous
that would really be though
okay maybe I should go for this move
even if it allows the night check that
shouldn't be anything I just
I just duck I don't see any tactical
issues with this move
strong piece
night on e5
okay and they're just prepared to
recapture
rook here
let's just go here
get out of any tricks maybe maybe I back
off on my bishop my knight I think is
best placed on this square d6 I'm else
ready for that
okay can I not clamp down I'm gonna
clamp down
yeah cuz now this and then a night here
and I haven't I should have an iron grip
over the the kingside yeah this is
excellent so now I could think about
flushing my opponent back some starting
with this move or not night here
coordinating on this square
maybe I play this first
- double then I on the clock here
can also think about pivoting like this
I don't want both rooks coming off but I
think that's going to happen
another
tough ending here ahead of us
sneak over have this square I could have
won this pawn are you goof it's
expecting them to just take with their
king
I still wanted one rook out I want one
rook still on board I need to make a
break
an item
it's tricky
target this if I can
I want to exchange my knight for this
first rank Knight
here I want this to be a target
eventually
I could have given a check
eventually Bishop a3 could be a move
all right
this up
all right let's go here and then jump in
like one of their nights is
to dad
take with this guy because I want this
square and then here can they defend
that
could take here now a check
pressure on this pond so the night is
glued to that square now I can make
progress
I could win the King in on anything I
could take here I have this move one
tempo and now my king is able to make
progress
let's go here
and then map up some
okay they resigned poof another tough
ending here with did minor pieces what
was it the second last game against
lucid chess these endings they were very
very close
very very close
okay still three games going let's have
a look at one of them
chickened seeing many games with chicken
here chicken versus cambot I'll have a
look at the final standings
nine round vamp okay he got that one
chickened
with the W and that's it those three
games they are all now finished I ended
up with 9 116 competed thank you all for
competing
these are I've been enjoying the Swiss
tournaments
quite a bit lately
anthurium finishing with seven and a
half lucid chess seven
chasidy s17 amazon river seven and there
is your page one let's go through them
all
again if you if you're looking to maybe
compete in these I've been updating
Twitter and posting a form too
the team right here
when I go live but you could see when
there's an upcoming one it'll be in
orange when there's an upcoming one so
feel free to connect if you would like
to take part in these Swiss tournaments
let's go through all the pages
as page two
see who competed
three
yeah this is a really nice turnout about
40 40 players participated in the and
the past ones at most still new
still in beta
but yeah a lot of fun these are the
Swiss format be able to create one you
could do up to a hundred rounds I've
only been playing around good games all
you've been chatting it up there you
could play it you could set it you could
create a Swiss tournament up to a
hundred rounds I've only played around
so far with the Blitz format but uh
the bullet would maybe be interesting
too I'm not sure doing a hundred rounds
is great definitely need a lot of
players competing for that but you know
feel free to connect if you'd like to
take part in the Swiss ones
good games all
you